Diejenigen von euch, die schonmal in Deutschland
waren
oder vielleicht sogar in Deutschland wohnen,
kennen das.
Man ist neu in Deutschland
und hier sind ein paar Dinge einfach anders.
Manche von euch hatten vielleicht sogar schon
mal einen
regelrechten Kulturschock.
Um euch den zu ersparen, werden wir euch heute
mal
acht Dinge erklären, die ihr nicht in Deutschland
tun solltet
und werden euch die auch mit unserem
schauspielerischen Talent demonstrieren.
- Los geht's!
Hallo, das ist ein Fahrradweg!
Meine persönliche Nummer Eins ist: Auf dem
Fahrradweg stehen.
Es ist ein bisschen schwer zu erklären,
warum das die Deutschen so nervt.
Aber tatsächlich ist das etwas, was mich
persönlich auch nervt.
Ganz oft sieht man Touristen in Deutschland,
die nicht wissen, dass das ein Fahrradweg
ist,
die da einfach mittendrauf stehen.
Und wichtig für euch zu wissen ist, dass
das Fahrrad
in Deutschland grundsätzlich mehr ist als
nur ein Mittel,
um Sport zu machen.
Viele Deutsche fahren mit dem Fahrrad
tatsächlich zur Arbeit oder machen Einkäufe.
Und für die ist das genau so wichtig,
wie Autofahren oder U-Bahnfahren.
Und jetzt stellt euch mal vor, ihr fahrt mit
dem Auto zur Arbeit
und da stehen plötzlich ständig Touristen
auf der Straße rum.
Hola Cari! - Wo bleibst du denn?
Ich hab' schon 'ne halbe Stunde auf dich gewartet.
Oh, das tut mir Leid, Cari.
Auch wir Deutschen sind nicht immer pünktlich.
Aber tatsächlich ist es so, dass in Deutschland
Pünktlichkeit einen ziemlich hohen Stellenwert
hat
und man ist nicht nur selbst pünktlich, man
erwartet schon
auch Pünktlichkeit von den anderen.
Wenn ihr also aus einem Land kommt, in dem
es vielleicht okay ist,
auch mal zwanzig oder dreißig Minuten später
zu kommen,
dann solltet ihr versuchen, das in Deutschland
nicht unbedingt
zu machen, denn hier kann es durchaus sein,
dass die Leute
euch das übel nehmen und dann etwas genervt
reagieren.
Cari, warum machst du nicht auf?
Ich steh' vor deiner Tür,
ich dachte, wir machen spontan was.
Achso, okay.
Ja, na dann halt nicht.
Deutsche lieben es, zu planen.
Und das gilt auch für Freizeitaktivitäten.
Es passiert nicht selten, dass Menschen ihre
Freizeitaktivitäten
mehrere Tage oder sogar schon Wochen im Voraus
verplanen.
Und der Nachteil davon ist natürlich:
Man ist selten bereit zu Spontanität.
Wenn jetzt also ein Freund von dir plötzlich
vor der Tür steht
und sagt: ""Hey, lass uns doch, ähm, spontan
ein Bier trinken!"",
dann sind viele Deutsche damit schlichtweg
überfordert.
Schließlich ist der ganze Tag schon verplant.
Kann der Freund sich das nicht denken?
Ich arbeite doch gerade.
Danach muss ich kochen, dann essen,
dann den Abwasch machen, dann Yoga und dann
kommt Tatort,
der ganze Abend ist schon verplant.
Neeeiiiin!
Das sind fünfundzwanzig Cent!
In Deutschland gibt es Flaschenpfand.
Das bedeutet, dass wenn man eine Flasche ausgetrunken
hat,
man sie nicht in den Mülleimer schmeißt,
sondern sie zurückbringt zum Supermarkt oder
zum Laden
und dann bekommt man bei einer Glasflasche
acht Cent zurück
und bei so einer Plastikflasche sogar fünfundzwanzig
Cent.
Das heißt, Flaschen immer aufbewahren und
beim nächsten Mal
mit zurückbringen oder wenn ihr gerade in
der Stadt seid,
lasst sie einfach vor dem Mülleimer stehen,
denn ganz sicher
wird sie dann jemand aufsammeln und zurückbringen,
damit er das Geld bekommt.
Frische Melonen, frische Früchte, frische
Früchte, frische Melonen.
Ja, ähm.
Was kostet so eine Melone?
- Das steht doch auf dem Schild.
Ja, aber das sieht man nicht.
Ich kann es nicht lesen.
Ja, müssen Sie halt die Melone wegnehmen.
- Pff...
Im Deutschen gibt es den schönen Spruch:
Der Kunde ist König.
Doch erst, wenn man mal als Deutscher in ein
anderes Land fährt,
weiß man, was das eigentlich bedeutet.
Denn tatsächlich ist die Servicekultur in
Deutschland
gar nicht so ausgeprägt, wie in vielen anderen
Ländern.
Und je nachdem, wo man in Deutschland ist,
wird das manchmal sogar noch schlimmer.
Hier in Berlin ist das so, zum Beispiel:
Wenn man in ein Geschäft geht oder in ein
Restaurant
und da etwas fragt oder sogar irgendwie auf
einen Fehler hinweist,
dann reagiert das Personal manchmal richtig
gestresst
und in manchen Fällen richtig unangenehm.
Ey, es (das) ist 'n Gehweg!
Die Deutschen nehmen im Großen und Ganzen
die Verkehrsregeln
ziemlich ernst.
Und nicht nur nehmen die meisten Menschen
sie selbst ernst, sondern es gibt auch sogenannte
""Hilfssherrifs"".
So nennen wir die Leute, die gerne andere
Leute darauf hinweisen,
wenn sie einen Fehler machen.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel mal nachts
auf dem Fahrrad unterwegs bin und gerade die
Batterie
von meinem Licht ausgeht, dann passiert es
schonmal,
dass mir jemand hinterherruft: ""Licht an!""
Frische Früchte, frische Melonen.
Hallo!
- Eine Melone bitte!
- Drei Euro.
Ja, mit Karte bitte.
Äh, sehen Sie hier irgendwo 'n Kreditkartengerät?
Nur Bargeld!
Ohne Bargeld ist man in Deutschland tatsächlich
oft aufgeschmissen.
Es gibt auch in 2020 noch viele Orte in Deutschland,
(an) denen man nur mit Bargeld zahlen kann,
zum Beispiel viele Cafés, Bars oder Restaurants.
Das heißt, wenn ihr nach Deutschland kommt,
solltet ihr unbedingt
Geld dabei haben und nicht unbedingt damit
rechnen,
dass ihr überall mit eurer Kreditkarte zahlen
könnt.
Warum ist das so?
Der Grund ist ein bisschen,
dass die Deutschen diesem Hartgeld mehr vertrauen
und deswegen ist es auch nicht ungewöhnlich,
dass Menschen in Deutschland über hundert
Euro im Portemonnaie
mit sich rumtragen, damit man immer für alles
vorbereitet ist.
Hey Janusz.
Alles Gute schonmal zum Geburtstag!
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein!
Heute gratuliert man nicht,
erst morgen.
Mein Geburtstag ist morgen.
Eh?
Warum?
Weil ... es, es bringt Unglück.
Ah okay, alles klar.
Die Deutschen sind im Großen und Ganzen eigentlich
nicht besonders
abergläubig, aber so ein, zwei Sachen gibt
es schon.
Und eine davon ist, dass man auf gar keinen
Fall jemandem
vor seinem Geburtstag gratulieren darf.
Das heißt,
wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel mit jemandem Abend
essen geht
und ihr verabschiedet euch um einundzwanzig,
zweiundzwanzig Uhr,
dann dürft ihr auf keinen Fall sagen:
""Ach, und du hast ja morgen Geburtstag.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch schonmal.""
Denn das bringt Unglück.
Jetzt seid ihr dran.
Wir wollen von euch wissen:
Welche komischen Situationen habt ihr erlebt
in Deutschland?
Gab es irgendwas, was ihr gelernt habt, was
man in Deutschland
auf keinen Fall tun sollte?
Schreibt uns einen Kommentar!
Und wenn ihr diese verrückten Aktionen, die
wir hier an einem
Samstagnachmittag, äh, betreiben, unterstützen
wollt,
dann werdet ein Patron, werdet ein Mitglied
von uns.
Damit unterstützt ihr unsere Arbeit
und ihr bekommt Übungen zu diesem Video und
einiges anderes.
Schaut euch das mal an, wir würden uns freuen!
Klickt einfach hier ... und hier.
Bis nächste Woche!
Tschüss!
Geh'n wir weg?